c'est l'une des bières les plus connus
de bourgogne avec 2 millions de
bouteilles produites cette année la
brasserie de vézelay tourne à plein
régime
vous voyez on est pas mal à l'e3 donc on
a absolument besoin d'espacé pour ça
qu'on a lancé la construction d'un
nouveau bâtiment qui se trouve derrière
on va doubler la superficie ce sera
livré fin février et ça nous permettra
de le ramener ces équipements ici et de
rajouter nouveaux tanks parce qu'on a
besoin absolument d'investir pour
pouvoir répondre à la demande qui est
très forte de la part de nos clients
face à cette forte demande la brasserie
artisanale a décidé d'investir un
million et demi d'euros supplémentaires
avec à la clé cette création d'emplois
et des outils de production plus
performant
cet investissement il va nous permettre
de suivre la demande de clients qui sont
principalement la grande distribution en
france de pouvoir commencer à répondre
sur les successions qu'on a à l'export
auxquelles on a répondu mais façon très
timoré parce qu'on n'a pas assez de
capacité de production et surtout de
développer une activité qu'on n'avait
pas développé pour l'instant qui est le
faire du chu parce que les fortes
demandes notamment sur paris
la brasserie artisanale un secteur en
pleine expansion
la bourgogne compte aujourd'hui une
trentaine de brasseurs indépendants
et quand on sait que chaque français
consomme en moyenne 32 litres de bière
par an les brasseurs n'ont pas besoin de
se mettre la pression